[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien à toi de ma gueule
polnareff et vous plaire type autocad
dans l'assistance
monsieur lambert je vous accuse d'avoir
déjà usé de votre notoriété pour draguer
oui ou non non jamais non saïd ragga
l'amiable sinon je suis pas du tout un
dragueur non c'est vrai doit s juré
c'est les filles qui voudra durée non
mais je suis tellement timide que je
peux même pas aller je peux pas aller
voir une gonzesse produits demandés si
elle veut boire un verre avec coin ou si
elle veut danser aussi mais c'est une
réalité et ça c'est un truc de que j'ai
depuis l'âge de 12 ans si l'on prenait
des cours avec gilles verdez c'est sûr
de rien chopper je vous accuse d'avoir
je vous accuse d'avoir déjà volé quelque
chose dans un magasin ah ah ça oui
ah oui bon là je peux pas leur côté
arraché à moi ça a été
c'était une époque de ma vie où ça a été
très très loin même beaucoup trop loin
est d'accord et donc c'était le vraiment
le choix entre deux chemins le bon ou le
mauvais j'ai pris le bong j'ai eu du bol
et je suis venu à paris pour essayer de
faire du théâtre et quelqu'un là haut
qui était bienveillant s'est dit bon il
faut guider ce petit et il m'a guidé
dans la bonne direction qui se tient ce
pas raconter je comprends monsieur le
juge
gaffe les stocks je vous accuse d'être
parfois un fidèle en amour
ouais
[Rires]
c'est ouais j'ai eu des écarts mais je
sais mais pas fréquents pendant je sais
pas n'ayant pas freiné par de cinq ans
je ne sais pas fréquent ab je sais que
vous êtes un mec bien quand même juste
souvent non mais je crois je comprends
pas
georges 10 à 9 ans né et nora on sait on
sait jamais ah oui c'est vrai et une
oreille célibataires en plus c'est vrai
ah oui je vous le dis oh là vous vous en
êtes où d'ailleurs là à moi je suis
célibataire
non ok oui lalalala stuff
il est choquant même lambert moi
j'organise un petit smack ah ouais tu me
demandes gilbert a bien sûr effet il
fait notion est allé dans l'américaine
c'est mais c'est la timidité
non non j'en avais je vais attendre asa
ouais c'est que j'ai toujours considéré
les acteurs un peu comme des chiens
c'est à dire [ __ ] sied il s'assied
moment que je vous dis tu te lèves
il se lève bah ouais tu marches tu
marques tu parles tu parle justement tu
me dis fais un stage sur un smash qui a
justement tu peux faire que ça
cantonniers timidité c'est un réflexe à
6 bon alors et n'aura quoi et n'aura non
mais attendez c'est un ami en plus ça
n'empêche pas les shoots vous à midi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]